المغتربون الاتراك رقم مهم في معادله
الفوز في دور ثاني للانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه يعودون مره اخرى للتصويت في 73
دوله تعددهم اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين
واربعمائه الف ناخب تركي المسجل شارك منهم
نحو 54% في الدوري الاول للانتخابات وتقدم
اردوغان حاصلا على نحو 57 ونصف في المئه
من الاصوات متبوعا بمرشح المعارضه كمال
كريجدار اوغلو بنحو 40% تصويت الخارج في
تفاصيله حمل اكثر من دلاله خصوصا في دول
بعينها شكلت وعاء انتخابيا اذ يعيش غالبيه
المغتربين الاتراك غربيه اوروبا وكانت
المانيا الوعاء الابرز للناخبين بنحو
مليون ونصف مليون ناخب منح نحو ثلثي
الناخبين فيها اصواتهم لاردوغان بينما حاز
كلجدار اوغلو على نحو ثلث الاصوات ارجع
محللون في وسائل اعلام غربيه مثل صحيفتي
النتيجه الى بينها استقرار العمال
المهاجرين في الستينيات حيث كان الاتراك
الاوائل الذين قدموا الى المانيا في
الغالب من سكان المناطق ريفيه المحافظه في
الاناضول وليس بعيدا دعم نحو 63% من
الناخبين الاتراك في المانيا عام 2017
التعديلات الدستوريه التي اقترحها اردوغان
لم تتخلف فرنسا عن جارتها المانيا مانحه
تفوقا مماثلا لاردوغان بنحو ثلثي الاصوات
مع حاله الشد والجذب التي طبعت علاقات هذا
البلد بتركيا برر محللونا في الصحف
الفرنسيه مثل لوفيغارو النتيجه بشعبيه
اردوغان بين اجيال متلاحقه من المهاجرين
المولودين في فرنسا جاء ابائهم من مناطق
اكثر محافظه في وسط وشمال الاناضول اضافه
الى دور اردوغان على المستوى الدولي حتى
شبهته
هذا الارتباط يوجد في دول اوروبيه اخرى
وفق الاكروال الفرنسيه مثل وهولندا
وبلجيكا التي كما تظهره الارقام صوتت
لصالح اردوغان بشكل مريح وبفريق مع منافسه
بالمجمل باللون الاحمر الدول التي منح
فيها الاتراك في الخارج التفوق لك خصوصا
في اوروبا الشرقيه وروسيا واسرائيل
وبالبرتقال دول صوتت لصالح اردوغان بينها
دول غربيه اوروبا والدول العربيه على
الامارات وسلطنه عمان لكن الصوره تبقى غير
كامله فالاهم يرتبط بالثقل الانتخابي اذ
ان 5 دول فقط في اوروبا الغربيه وهي
المانيا وفرنسا وهولندا وبلجيكا والنمسا
تمثل نصف عدد الناخبين تقدم فيها اردوغان
وشكلت لوحدها نحو 83% من اصواته وكان
حصاده اقل في دول مثل الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا اللتين صوت فيها الاتراك بنسب
تروحت بين
79% لصالح كريجدار اوغلو بينما كانت
الفجوه بين المرشحين اقل في استراليا
اختلف التصويت الناخبين الاتراك في الخارج
يلتقي الجميع في انتمائهم لوطن واحد لكن
بدت للمغتربين اولويه مختلفه عن مواطنيهم
في بلدهم الام ولهم اسبابهم ودوافعهم التي
صنعت وجهه اصواتهم